[Music]
hey guys my name is chef lawrence paige
from the pink teacup we're making
cornbread crab cakes can you imagine
that have you ever heard anything like
that it is going to be delish
you know what cornbread was a mistake
when i started making this recipe i kid
you not i didn't have any bread crumbs
in the house at the time and i wanted
some crab cakes so i had everything in
the house to make the crab cakes but i
didn't have the bread crumbs to bind it
together but i did have some old
cornbread left over from the night
before i said let me try the cornbread
i'm from the south i'm sure i can whip
it up so i took the cornbread i crumbled
it up actually put it in the ingredient
and guess what it bind it perfect and
the taste of the cornbread came through
the sweetness with the saltiness of the
crab was the perfect balance
[Music]
this right here is fresh crab lump
this is how crab look looks different
from being out of the shell right you
don't have to worry about it there's no
shells in it it's clean already they
prepared it for you it's nice fresh the
color is amazing sometimes you'll see a
little bit moisture left in the crab
that's okay that's we like to call that
crab juice today as long as it's not
pouring out like a glass of water you
want to make sure it's nice and even
break it down you don't want too lumpy
pick it up from the bottom i want to be
able to see them breadcrumbs i want to
be able to see that red pepper that
cilantro look at that i want to feel
that moist in my hand you see those
colors
[Music]
i'm going to grab a couple of my hand
like a little bit at night four fingers
worth you know put it there it depends
on who's coming to dinner if i want it
big i can make it big if i want it small
i could make it small it's like a little
hockey puck now watch your fingers as
you're putting this in you don't want to
burn your fingers so as you can see it's
bubbling up around it you want to wait a
minute and just lift it up a little you
don't want to go right now okay it's not
burning perfect getting that brown
flavor look at that that's nice
boy that's nice
and you want the center to cook a little
bit so a lot of times you want to turn
it down just a little bit and let it sit
there and cook you want that heat to hit
the inside of the craft so it can melt
all those flavors together you want them
to mesh right together
look at that that's beautiful isn't that
beautiful
this is amazing y'all got to taste this
oh yes
[Music]
you